الثقافي الذي تتغنى به مدينه انطاكيا
التاريخيه اصبح اليوم مهددا بشكل كبير بعد
ان دمر زلزال الزلزال هذه المدينه وفق
صحيفه التي اعتبرت انه قبل الزلزال كانت
انطاكيا عاصمه اقليميه صاخبه تشتهر
بماكولاتها وكنائسها ومعابدها اليهوديه
ومساجدها التي تعود الى قرون لكنها اليوم
مدينه مدمره بالكامل المدينه القديمه
لانطاكيا دمرت بالكامل اذا بعد ان حافظت
على التعدديه الدينيه لسكانها من مسلمين
ومسيحيين ويهود اتراك واليوم معظمهم غادر
المدينه حيث فرت الجاليه اليهوديه باكملها
من المدينه مما قد يهدد الوجود اليهودي
الذي يعود تاريخه الى اكثر من 2000 عام في
انطاكيا وغادر اخرون ايضا فيما بما في ذلك
جميع الطوائف المسيحيه الارثوذكسيه
والكاثوليكيه والبروتستانتيه من هذه
المدينه تقريبا
[موسيقى]